Speaker 1: All right, let's get into audience
questions for the week, the first one is related
to the Cuban protests and and a situation
that we've been talking about there for about
ten days now.
David, why do some protests get so much more
media attention than others?
For example, there are currently protests
happening in Guatemala and South Africa, and
yet we hear nothing about them in American
media, but we hear a lot about Cuba.
Why is this so the answer?
There's two different answers.
First, there's a sort of a commercialization
of media answer and then there's a political
answer.
And in the case of Cuba, it's actually a little
bit of both.
But it's absolutely true in the sense that
first, let's figure out if the situations
are different in terms of their level of notoriety
in Cuba.
We've seen significant protests as well as
serious crackdowns, many videos getting out
of Cuban police, federal, local police, you
know, variety of different levels of law enforcement
in Cuba, just grabbing people, holding signs
off the street and a significant and serious
crackdown.
The protests have been related to mishandling
of covid out of control, inflation, a collapsing
economy, lack of resources, lack of food,
all sorts of different things.
Similarly, in South Africa.
There have been at least 32 people killed
in clashes between police and protesters.
The president of South Africa ordered soldiers
to the country's two most densely populated
provinces because crowds were ransacking retail
stores.
And the protests were in response to the jailing
of the former president, Jacob Zuma.
And there's it's been significantly chaotic
in South Africa.
Similarly, in Guatemala, there have been demands
for the resignation of the president over
his mishandling of the covid pandemic, a shortage
of vaccines, et cetera.
There were protests there in Guatemala City,
as well as in other regions denouncing the
president's handling of the situation, demands
for the president giammetti to step down.
And cases are skyrocketing.
Hospitals are about to collapse.
Very low vaccination rate, significant chaos
in Guatemala.
But yet we barely hear about those in American
media, but we hear about Cuba.
So what is the explanation?
There's really two one up.
The history of U.S. Cuban relations is a big
part of it.
Cuban circumstances in Cuba relate to so many
American political stories, including this
battle over socialism and communism, that
the right has been fighting against communists
like Joe Biden.
I mean, that's ridiculous, right?
But it's very useful for the right to talk
about Cuba and anything bad that happens in
Cuba.
There's also a much more important from a
political standpoint, Cuban-American population
in terms of its impact on the results in Florida.
And so politically, it's a much more useful
population.
You know, most non Guatemalans are super concerned
about the Guatemalan American vote as a voting
bloc in the United States for them.
And this applies to Argentinean Americans
like me.
And.
Right.
I mean, there's there's just less political
utility.
Mexico is certainly an interesting one because
of political reasons, and Cuba is as well.
Similarly, South African Americans not like
Cuban Americans in terms of a group that a
state can hinge on.
So in particular, in that context, it's logical
that we're hearing more about Cuba than we
are about Guatemala and South Africa.
And then there's just like the straight up
commercial narrative story, which narrative
is going to make news viewers tune in the
longest and either happy or angry at someone
so that they continue to share articles and
sort of engage because that drives ratings
and ad revenue.
Because of the first piece that I mentioned,
there's not as much need or interest in appealing
to Guatemalan Americans or South African Americans.
It's not going to drive ratings.
It's not going to drive news revenue.
Talking about Cuba, very, very much does.
And it's a similar question actually to why
do some shootings get more attention than
others?
The right loves to say only shootings of minorities
by white people get attention because that
serves the left.
The left often points out that the right in
general doesn't want to talk about shootings
unless the perpetrator is nonwhite.
And it's like very, very clean along racial
lines.
Both stories are the reality is there's much
more to it.
There's power dynamics.
There's what was it an officer involved shooting
or was this civilians?
But there's also I mean, when you look at
how many mass shootings take place every day,
there's clearly a selection.
Bias that's taking place and it's much similarly
oriented along the same lines to two things
one, what will generate interest from the
standpoint of being a news story?
And number two, which shootings are of political
relevance to either or both sides?
And it's a very similar thing with which with
the story of which protests get attention.
There's something I'm missing in this analysis
is there's more to it.
Guatamala, South Africa, Cuba, certainly.
Let me know.
I would love to
hear it.